hi I'm Erik Bosse and Game of Thrones
might be over but there are still two
books left to read and write George but
how different will the a Song of Ice and
Fire series ending be to the finale of
the HBO series I guess it depends on
which of the angry tweets at george RR
martin reads but welcome to Westeros
weekly as you can see it's just me here
this week so it might get a little weird
I guess it's story time with Erik he
Wee's Playhouse sounds good whatever
you'll see there's gonna be some
puppetry going on and a reminder that
actually you can get all of our Game of
Thrones coverage on our Westeros weekly
podcast feed it's gonna continue to
release good game of Thrones content
about this series that we just watched
book Theory's prequel news that will be
coming out so make sure to stay
subscribed we got some exciting stuff
coming but let us get started today with
our big question delivered to us today
by our house Rayven uh you know what
you've been so great this season Rayven
so how about we Knight to you i dub the
sir plot twist how does that sound it's
the writers having their playbook this
season no twist anyway the question
brought to us by the notorious BGI asks
how will the books play out differently
that's a great question I'm sure a lot
of people didn't click away from this
right now because of that let's talk
about the alternate Indians four
characters in the books and actually
some alternate Indians that have been
rumored to have been shot for this show
so george RR martin still has two books
to finish in his A Song of Ice and Fire
series the winds of winter and a dream
of spring and between the two of them
that will be around 3,000 pages of
manuscript there so there's still a lot
of Game of Thrones content left for us
to devour
despite statements from Barristan Selmy
actor Ian McIlhenny that Martin had
actually finished the books years ago
and secretly kept them under wraps so
let the HBO series finish Martin has
actually come out to say that he hasn't
begun writing a dream of spring yet and
won't even begin until winds of winter
has finished but that is a good sign
because it means he's
working on the winds of winter which a
lot of us were worried about Martin was
asked whether the books ending will be
the same and he responded with what was
my favorite quote ever he goes Wow yes
and no and yes and no and yes and no and
yes and for anyone keeping track there
that's four ways the book ending will be
the same in three ways it will be
different so is everyone satisfied are
we done
great no no no okay no no all right
let's dig into that Martin has signaled
in the past that the fates of the main
characters will be the same so that
means Daenerys will probably still go
mad John will still probably kill her in
some way and end up venturing north and
Arya will still probably go west of
Westeros and perhaps bran will still be
named King bran the broken but if those
fates seemed disappointing to you I
highly encourage you to read the books
if you don't already because they
contain so much more context in detail
that I think will make these end results
more satisfying because we'll have
longer journeys to go on and more
context to see from their points of view
so we understand their inner thought
processes for example a dance with
dragons leaves Daenerys in a place in
which her rise in power was already
starting to waver she didn't really seem
like such an epic hero in the books
she's more of a complex figure as we saw
in seasons five and six on the show
ruling Meereen is something that
Daenerys never really figures out and we
kind of forget that with the show but in
the books it's very clear that she isn't
the destined ruler that we like to think
of her as when we see Emilia Clarke's
portrayal throughout the series also in
the books there's the character young
Griff aka
Aegon the sixth he's the son of Rhaegar
and Elia Martell who survived the sack
of King's Landing and already has his
own plans to marry Daenerys and invade
Westeros a very interesting character to
follow there is not on the show they
wrote him out of the show he's only in
the books so but there's already
evidence of a secret Targaryen in in in
the mix for Daenerys just like John is
on the show and there's already ways
that her claim to the Iron Throne will
be greatly disrupted in the books and
you gotta add that to a ton of other
political complications that didn't
happen the show like drama in Dorne and
Dorne was not really a big factor on the
show but in the books it's such a big
player in that game
there's Victorian gradually in the show
we've only had your on Greyjoy who kind
of combines elements of Victorian and
his book counterpart but Victorian
Greyjoy is another big player that
complicates Daenerys his journey to the
Iron Throne
all of this is going to cause book
Daenerys as Westeros campaign to be a
lot more complicated and in my opinion a
far more of a tragic fall for her
character making her less heroic in our
eyes and making it seem less out of
character for her to torch King's
Landing a lot of people complained with
the show foreshadowing it's not
character development even though the
plot elements are there I think in the
books it'll feel a lot more like
character development that this is her
journey as a tragic hero also in all of
Daenerys his chapters we just got to
remember we will see her descent in a
madness from her point of view you know
it'll be a little make a lot more sense
when we're able to read her thoughts and
understand her inner emotions in her
inner world and I'm guessing don't make
a lot more sense for people who are
reading books than just watching
Daenerys seem to maybe hate the sound of
bells so much that she decides to murder
a million people it'll make more sense I
feeling similarly there's the question
of Jon Snow so a dance with dragons
actually leaves Jon dying from stab
wounds from the Nights Watch mutineers
that we saw at the end of season 5 in
the end of that book we don't understand
whether he lives or dies his
resurrection was something new on the
show presumably Martin still intends to
resurrect Jon in the books and reveal
him as the son of Rhaegar and Lyanna
because remember when Dave and Dan asked
Martin to adapt the books for HBO way
back when they had to correctly answer
who was Jon Snow's real mother so
presumably this is a reveal that Martin
also has in mind for the books the HBO
series never draws firm conclusions
about Jon's resurrection that kind of
move on past it and kind of lightly
referenced it or really the importance
of his Targaryen bloodline or his
connection to the prophecy of azor Ahai
/ the prince that was promised a lot of
you guys were annoyed that the show
didn't dig into that more but the books
have always given more context about
things like prophecy dark magic and
mythology book John experiences a number
of dream
and visions that he never experiences on
the show there's actually evidence that
John along with characters like bran
Arya the other star children have war
have a warg like linked to their dire
wolves in the dire wolves of course are
another super fascinating element of the
show mostly ignored after the earlier
seasons but in the books there's far
greater symbolic connection to the main
characters now a dream of spring may
still arrive in a place in which John
has to kill a Mad Queen Daenerys and
then return north but think about this
maybe his physical state post
resurrection could be way different in
the books like in the show he was just
basically Kit Harington again with a
couple scars and a lot of plot armor but
maybe in the books he lives on in a
different way like before we knew that
John Snow would resurrect we thought
maybe he would reincarnate or embody the
body of ghost his direwolf and he could
live on in the body of ghost and fulfill
his destiny as a as a ghost as an undead
presence so it you know it kind of works
to Ozar
that was one theory and his final words
in the book were ghost he whispered that
and there was like a lot of theories
that we all had from the end of that
book but he could also follow the
footsteps of another undead resurrected
corpse that only exists in the books
Lady Stoneheart that is the corpse of
Catelyn Stark she shows up in the
Riverland after the red wedding she has
a gash in her neck from when she was
killed at the red wedding she has to
cover that gash to talk
she's resurrected she doesn't say much
but she is a terrifying villainous
figure she joins them the Brotherhood
without banners she murders a bunch of
phrase throughout the Riverlands to get
vengeance for the red wedding she
becomes a villain to Brienne of Tarth
and Podrick and the last we leave off
with those characters Brienne and
Podrick are at the gallows and Catelyn /
Lady Stoneheart has charged them to
murder Jaime Lannister or be hanged we
don't really know what Bryan's final
word was that she shouts out but it's
assumed that she's willing to go forward
with that charge similarly imagine a an
undead version of Jon Snow Lord snow
like maybe his throat is still slashed
doesn't talk much
those
nothing but he could be out for
vengeance against the Bolton's the
waiting load Lady Stoneheart was against
the phrase so the two families mostly
responsible for the red wedding along
with the Lannisters will have vengeance
from two undead Ravagers throughout the
northern territories in the Riverlands
that could be a really cool destiny for
Jon Snow especially since it seems like
kind of a dim character he could take on
this new undead zombie future especially
since the books don't really have a
version of the night king the way that
the Choate did that was a show creation
they have the night's king which is this
kind of prophesied figure but instead
the others could be like walking amongst
us as opposed to this existential threat
and imagine this version of Lord snow he
could strike back at his knights watch
mutineers the way that Jon Snow actually
did but it would be a lot scarier to see
this Lord snow version do it he could
take back Winterfell from the Bolton's
lead a campaign for the throne and end
with him having to kill Danny and return
north that all makes sense and it'd be
really fun to read that in the books I
know I'm fanfiction right now but this
is a way that they could still arrive at
the same end point but through a
completely different journey like
whenever you see a really villainous
protagonist who's less sympathetic it's
a lot easier to track them as they're
doing crazy stuff as opposed to judging
this attractive actor who've learned to
love and root for in every possible way
in the same way that the books could
make John a less human figure who still
reaches the same end point the show they
could reverse that with bran and make
the three-eyed Raven less of a hollow
stump and more of an actual person so
like crowning him doesn't feel like a
dinner for Schmucks that votes a schmuck
to take over the dinner in the books the
three-eyed Raven is rumored to be
Brynden rivers the Bloodraven a bastard
son of King Aegon the fourth Targaryen
legitimized by Aegon the fourth and when
ended up warring with his bastard
siblings for the throne the Blackfyre
rebellion ended up taking the black kind
of a parallel figure to John if you
think about it but the Bloodraven would
only be around 150 years old not a
thousand years that it was he was
implied to be in the show he's weird but
you know he's still a person so the same
could happen for bran he could be branch
but you know with the ch branched off
and back to the closer version of brand
that we all know and love and maybe some
day a choice for King that actually
makes sense because he's still a human
and he still seems like someone who can
have a normal conversation with someone
it doesn't go off and roll his eyes back
and disappear mid-conversation
now according to the TV writers there's
that question of like alternate endings
and there was an alternate ending that
was outlined or scripted that John had
Jorah Mormont joining him and tormund in
their final ride north of the wall in
the final scene of the series perhaps
that's something that we'll see in the
books as well also in the books remember
Barristan Selmy is still alive and he
goes on to play a way bigger role with
Dany in Essos so I think when you're
reading the books you can expect to read
more of that as well
sources from HBO have said that no
alternate endings were filmed as was
previously rumored you know there's that
idea that they were trying to hide what
the real ending was but there was one
fake scene that was shot it was Cersei
meeting with Jon Snow in King's Landing
this was to cover up her death in the
destruction of the red keep in episode 5
so they did shoot that and maybe we'll
see that on like blu-ray or bonus
material at some point I think we can
expect the final two books mostly what
I'm most excited about to further
explore the mythology of the White
Walkers known as the others in the books
they really rename them for the show
their connection to these children the
forest maybe connection to the
three-eyed Raven and you know what
hopefully in the books they'll structure
them in a different way not in that hive
structure where killing the central
knight king kills them all it just felt
pretty simple and cinematic I guess it
kind of made sense on the show but to
read that in a book it wouldn't have
that same kind of payoff or satisfaction
so hopefully they won't have that kind
of central node structure Martin has
also said about his books if nothing
else the readers will learn what
happened to Jane Poole Lady Stoneheart
penny and her pig scars shave pate our
area and Martell Dark Star Victoria and
Greyjoy sir Garland the gallant Aegon
the 6th in a myriad of other characters
both great and small that the viewers of
the show never had a chance to meet now
it's interesting that he singles out
Jane Poole they're all these characters
are fascinating I'm not gonna go into
all of them because you always have to
read the books but Jane Poole is largely
Sansa storyline from season 5 Jane was
one of Santa's Winterfell buddies who
went down with her to King's Landing
when Ned was made the hand of the king
and after everything went down she was
handed over to Ramsay Bolton by
Littlefinger
Littlefinger claimed that she was Arya
Stark it just to try to forge an
alliance with with Ramsay Bolton so that
he could get a better claim to the north
as the Lord of Winterfell and the way
that Ramsay Bolton married Sansa he
married Jane pool slash Arya in the
books and Jane suffered many of the same
things that Sansa suffered at Winterfell
she was tortured she eventually escaped
Winterfell with beyond just like Sansa
did so if Jane's story goes on forward
the way that scientists did in season
six and seven it might mean
Sansa story will play out quite
differently in the books and Martin was
asked which ending would be the real
ending between the show and the books
and he responded how about this I'll
write it you read it then everyone can
make up their own mind and argue about
it on the internet which I'm sure we
will all do he knows us so well here's
my final note on this and I'm stepping
away from the final season I'm still
kind of processing and re-evaluating it
the other day I don't really have a
problem with Daenerys descending into
madness or with John killing her or with
bran becoming the king or Tyrion
becoming the hand it all kind of makes
sense from a overall outline standpoint
but as we all watched it episode by
episode I think those arcs were just
really oddly plotted in season seven and
eight and it made those final strokes
feel really unearned but I truly truly
hope that George are Martin has
different fates in mind for Jaime and
Cersei the more I think about the more I
just cannot rationalize why season 8 did
the things with him that they did so if
we take Martin insanely literally on his
yes-no yes-no response that I mentioned
earlier I'm thinking the four ways the
books will end the same will be in
regards to Daenerys John bran and Arya
may be same end point but just hopefully
different journeys so they're different
people by the time they get to those end
points and the three ways that it'll be
different hopefully will be with Jaime
and Cersei and then maybe a different
story for Sansa and maybe for Brienne
too since all these other storylines
will be changed sound good let's move on
to another question hey sir plot twist
what are you doing down there don't ask
if you don't want it
Oh
No okay so what's the next question it's
Splash Marsh 1-9 asks what do you expect
from the spin-off series Oh get back
down there yes okay yeah let's talk
about the spin-off series it's prequel
that's in development and there's
actually yeah there's five of them
there's five spin-off projects that
started one might be going away because
Bryan cogman his was shut down and he's
going to now work on the Amazon series
the Lord of the Rings series that
they're doing but one of those spin-off
projects is has started shooting this
summer here's what we know about the
secretive spin-off George or Martin has
called it the successor show it will be
written and produced by Jane Goldman who
wrote x-men first class in the Kingsmen
movies she's great writer the cast has
been announced including Naomi Watts and
a bunch of other relative unknowns who
will be stars now on the show it is set
thousands of years before the events of
Game of Thrones so we likely won't see
any characters we recognize but maybe
we'll see the night king his origins
learn some more about him or maybe the
three-eyed Raven before a brand the Max
von Sydow one or maybe one of the older
ones in that line of succession assuming
it is a succession and it sounds like
it'll be set during the Age of Heroes in
the long night so just to remind you
about when the Age of Heroes was this
was before the Targaryen invasion of
Westeros before Aegon the conquerer
forged the Iron Throne it was a time
after the first men made peace with the
children of the forest and there were a
lot of famous characters roaming
Westeros and became these legendary
figures of course there's bran the
Builder founder of House Stark first
king of the north builder of the wall in
the north and he was rumored to have
built lots of other structures he was
rumored to have helped build storm's end
that castle down in the Stormlands there
was also the figure land the clever
founder founder of House Lannister who
famously tricked the castor leaves out
of their family home of Casterly Rock
yeah with lots of apocryphal different
stories of tricks that he use coding
himself in butter and sneaking into the
into the castle walls and yeah he's
these a weird fascinating guy that bran
actually seems to have a vote in this
season saying the founder of your family
to Jaime and Tyrion was just as much of
a trickster as I'm being there's also
the figured
gods grief who fought founded the
precursor to house baratheon and might
have married a God's daughter according
to legend Garth greenhand was also the
first king of the reach in the Tyrell
forefather there was the grey king of
the Iron Islands who might have married
a mermaid and defeated a sea dragon what
is about stories that just tend to get
crazier and wilder the more millennia
that pass
now these stories are really like fairy
tales but their defining myths of the
areas and families of Westeros so
whatever things they've made up have
informed the personality in the outlook
of all these families so they're
important in that way
now just remind of what the long night
was that was the winter that lasted the
length of a generation
according to old Nanking castles there
were ice spiders many of us were looking
forward to that in the show didn't
happen the White Walkers showed up for
the first time were defeated at the
battle for the dawn by the first men and
the children of the forest they were
pushed back north that's when bran the
Builder built the wall the Nights Watch
was created so there was a lot of like
dark history there we'll see if this
show will be set there hopefully HBO
learned his lessons about shooting
things at nighttime really what I'm most
excited about the show is it might
finally answer the question of the white
Walker the white walkers and the night
king the whatever mysteries were left
mysteries on the show hopefully the show
will dig into this more because there's
still so much mythology there that I
have questions about and if it does
explore the legend of the last hero that
northern legend that has a lot of
parallels with The Legend of azor Ahai
so maybe we'll get some questions about
the prince that was promised and the
azure Ahai prophecy and quickly about
the other successor shows and
development they are all set before the
events of Game of Thrones so we're not
really going to it sounds like we're not
gonna cover Robert's rebellion or The
Adventures of dunk and egg because
remark and is still kind of writing
those spin-off books he doesn't want to
compete with the show again which makes
sense he has hinted that one of these
shows will be based on fire and blood
that tells the story of the Attar garyun
invasion the forming of the Iron Throne
there's a lot of dragons there so we'll
depend on what kind of budget that has
because I have a feeling that they're
not gonna want to spend so much money on
dragons again
now we're gonna answer more of your
questions in for Game of Thrones season
8 and reveal the overall
and power rankings but first we want to
thank our sponsors who helped bring
Westers weekly to you our first sponsor
is hellofresh hellofresh is a meal kit
delivery service that shops
plans and delivers step-by-step recipes
and pre measured ingredients so you can
just cook eat and enjoy
they have really delicious and simple
recipes they do all the meal planning
and shopping and prepping for you so you
can just focus on being a healthier you
there are three plans to choose from
there's a classic the veggie and family
with the option to switch if you end up
changing your mind you can spend less
time meal planning and grocery shopping
so you could spend more time doing what
you love like you know debating the
merits of season eight and Game of
Thrones with literally every person in
your life it's just me just me probably
not hello fresh has simplified my dinner
time and the food is awesome
I try to pulled pork Fiesta Bowl and a
cherry balsamic chicken those were my
favorites I love those it's become
hands-down my favorite meal kit delivery
service
so for $80 off your first month of
hellofresh go to hell afresh calm slash
rock stars 80 and enter promo code rock
stars 80 it's like receiving eight meals
free folks just go to hell afresh calm
slash rock stars 80 there to promo code
rock stars eighty four eighty dollars
off your first month of hellofresh meal
delivery kits our final sponsor this
week is a way travel they're a design
company that makes the world's coolest
suitcases they're made of polycarbonate
material that's strong and super light
perfect for sailing west of Westeros
with a real low profile ship with a
giant wolf head carved into the front
here's what it looks like this is there
everywhere bag which is great for small
trips and you know even just your
day-to-day life some of their other
models even come with a built in battery
to charge your electronic accessories
you can get your own cool away luggage
at away travel.com slash rock stars 20
and use promo code rock stars 20 for $20
off your order
again that's away travel.com slash rock
stars 20 and use promo code rock stars
20 for $20 off great so let's move on to
another question hey store plot twist
how's it going down there
it's all free hooks but here's another
question it says add sugar in spikes
asks was John or Arya Azure
I yeah that's a question a lot of us
have asked about okay so a quick
backstory the prince was promised of
course is the figure that the red
priestesses are all obsessed with he or
she is supposed to be azor Ahai reborn
and saved the world from darkness at
various points in the series Stannis
Baratheon
Daenerys John Arya they were all
considered frontrunners to be azor Ahai
reborn though none of them matched up
exactly with all the points of the
prophecy laid out in the books depending
on how metaphorical you wanted to be in
the interpretations of their life events
before these final seasons Daenerys
definitely seemed like the front runner
Melisandre implied that she would be the
princess who was promised Daenerys was a
descendant of the Mad King and Rey Ella
as the ghost of high heart in the books
predicted the prince that was promised
would be she was born beneath the
bleeding star if you consider her birth
being her rebirth when her dragons were
born that was the red comet was overhead
her over it overhead when that happened
she was born amidst salt and smoke smoke
from the funeral pyre and salt from her
tears and the tears of Mary master when
she was burned alive she awakened
dragons from stone she acquired a
metaphorical flaming sword in the form
of her dragons by sacrificing her Nissa
Nissa lover figure called Drogo
because only death could pay for life so
they were connected but with Daenerys
his villainous turn in season 8 all that
speculation kind of went out the window
faster than Tommen did in the Battle of
Winterfell arya proved to be really the
champion of the Lord of Light on the
show she struck the fatal blow against
the night king after motivation from
beric Dondarrion and Melisandre there's
lots of Lord of Light imagery in that
episode but you know champion status
doesn't make her the prince that was
promised or princess that was promised
exactly really john saved the world from
a different kind of darkness from
Daenerys and while that prophecy points
didn't all line up perfectly there they
were kind of present in another
metaphorical sense and that scene
Daenerys is John's Nissa Nissa
sacrificed figure flaming swords were
present in the melting of the Iron
Throne really based on all the Lord of
Light symbolism in the Battle of
Winterfell Arya seems to be that this
seems to be the show's pick for the
princess that was promised but based on
this you know metaphorical
interpretation of from the book details
John seems like more of the epic hero of
the show overall but I think we should
remember that he's
pasi's our background to motivate some
characters they are not a core mystery
that the show in the books were aiming
to solve the legend of azor Ahai
parallels the northern myth of the last
hero parallels other myths from Essos
just like in our real world mythology
every religion has its version of noah's
ark story and a worldwide flood so by
having these parallel myths in the world
of Westeros george RR martin has really
shown us that myths themselves are
powerful but they are not blueprints for
how everything will exactly go let's
move on to another question from Sir
plot twist hey chase hissed his brand
going to live forever and never give up
the throne ooh I hope not because man
how many generations are gonna get used
to a tree is their king bran meets the
three-eyed raven in season six and he
says that the branded three-eyed Raven
says that he's waited a thousand years
for bran and who then becomes a
three-eyed Raven right bran is the
three-eyed Raven now does that mean bran
it's gonna live for a thousand years and
basically be a forever king well the
three-eyed Raven has said that he's been
there for a thousand years but that
doesn't mean in that body
remember the three-eyed Raven is like a
title passed on from person to person so
maybe that's what he was referring to
the whole idea of the three-eyed Raven
existed back in the time of the children
of the forest but Max von Sydow wasn't
sitting there there was even a different
actor playing him on the show and but
every casting in the books it's actually
hinted that Brynden Bloodraven rivers I
mentioned him earlier he's a bastard of
King Aegon the fourth he's a real guy
and he would have only been 150 years
old rather than a thousand again the
show went a different place
the three-eyed Raven was living in the
roots of the weirwood tree which might
have helped him live longer than usual
as opposed to you know a mobile southern
brand who only has a personality of the
tree and is it really sitting there
amongst the roots of it hopefully turn
was right and bran will just be a wise
ruler and not a forever king but if he
does live longer than usual that
actually might be a good thing to have a
period of peace and stability
considering you know he's the southern
stark King might allow for a longer
alliance with the north rather than
another war between these kingdoms let's
move on to another question for
sir plot twist u95 asks what's the
punchline of Tyrians joke ah yes we know
this joke that was I once brought to
jackass and a honeycomb into a brothel
and then he always gets cut off he
brought it up in season 1 during its
confession before countless darken liza
aaron in the in the veil and he brought
it up again in season 6 and making a
little small talk with grey worm and
Masson day and marine and then his final
words in season 8 were him once again
setting up this joke to the small
council if you go watch the breakdown or
listen to the breakdown that i did of
the finale episode i presented what i
think is the best possibility for that
theory go check it out I'm not gonna
repeat here you got to go watch that for
it I didn't come up with it I found it
online I think it's brilliant but you
got to go watch that to find out let's
move on to our Power Rankings so after
each episode this season we asked you to
decide who won the episode by voting in
our online Power Rankings each week we
would compile all the votes and then
list the top three characters and now we
went back through some of you know our
exhaustive Excel spreadsheet work and we
compiled all the votes for the whole
season and did an overall season 8 Power
Rankings the results are pretty
interesting so in fifth place with 8.4
percent is brand brand the broken now
king of the six kingdoms which yeah if
you consider him the overall winner of
the Game of Thrones
yes that's it's hard to deny his power
at the end of the series in fourth place
Cersei Lannister despites her I would
say let down her defeat in episode 5 and
despite spending most of the season
sitting on balconies and sipping wine
despite being the master tactician that
she was in previous seasons she did
score some major victories and in the
way brought down Daenerys with her if
you look at it that way speaking of whom
in third place with 10.8 percent of the
vote Daenerys Targaryen
considered most powerful yes she did in
a way get what she wanted but maybe the
short-term goal of what she wanted not
the long-term goal of what she wanted
and had some great victory moments but
unfortunately in order to score those
victories had to follow in
three of her her father the Mad King and
make some choices that you know really
alien in a lot of people in second place
with thirteen point two percent of the
vote Sansa Stark Sansa Stark would be my
pick for four winner of this series or
at least should be in my top three
because yeah she gets the the title of
monarch that really I think most people
want you don't have to worry about the
warring factions of Westeros if you're
just queen of the north I can't say
queen of the north anymore because I've
only ever said queen queen or king a de
Norv but yeah she gets to just rule her
homeland and what's better than that I
think that finale montage definitely
presented her to be the most victorious
character aside from the far by and
large the first-place voter of our vote
of our power rankings with 31.7% Arya
Stark yeah she got what she wanted to by
going west of Westeros and yeah she was
super victorious by killing the night
king being the champion of the Lord of
Light in that moment and being this
interesting point of view character
throughout the destruction of King's
Landing
she was a victorious character i I
didn't really see her character change
over the course of this season but yeah
you could say she definitely scored a
great victory and she was really fun to
watch now for those wondering why wasn't
John in the top five I agree I think he
definitely deserves to be in the top
five he was sixth he placed just ahead
of the Hound and Tyrion two characters
who I think were super powerful as well
but yeah I think with a lot of people
John didn't really have earned power
moments other than his saving the realm
from the madness of Queen Daenerys and
really that was something he had to be
pressured to do by several characters
because a lot of his lines throughout
this season were she's my queen I don't
want it she's my queen
I don't want it so it might have felt
more powerful this is something that
John arrived at on his own despite how
hard it must have been for him to do
that in that moment and just a little
factoid here someone voted for Podrick
in every episode there was one vote for
Podrick Podrick
we know who we know it was you or you
know one of those woman he hooked up
with but hey Podrick definitely had a
victorious season as well he was
knighted what's better than that well
that's enough for this Westeros weekly I
want to thank you all for watching and
listening and don't forget to subscribe
westeros weekly podcast we've still got
more stuff coming out and be sure to
follow our new MCU podcast inside marvel
got some great Marvel related stuff
happening there you can follow us on
twitter at new rock stars you can follow
me on instagram and on twitter at a vas
thank you for all for joining me and
thank you for joining me sir plot twist
thank you for waiting me and where my
name stay the same in future episodes
probably not sir plot twist it's
probably not canon because this has only
happened because this is louise
playhouse and lots of weird things
happen now by the way if you're
listening on podcast be sure to watch
the video version of this because we
have little Easter eggs hidden all over
our set hope you found them all bye
[Music]